moi je trouve que elle est incroyable
parce qu'elle change totalement de
personnalité quand elle est sur le
plateau dans la vie elle est d'une
discrétion incroyable elle arrive elle
vient de bosser toute la journée elle
est discrète dans les toute la journée
et donc elle change totalement de
personnalité quand elle est là elle se
lâche elle balance elle dit des choses
et puis surtout ce que j'apprécie chez
elle c'est que elle ose dire les choses
même quand c'est à compte au courant ça
peut déranger donc je doute peut-être de
l'audace et ça ça mérite comme je suis
un sac 5 sur 10 c'est bon
c'est sévère c'est sévère moi je suis je
l'adore vous le savez sachal base alors
moi j'ai mis un 8
voilà pour les conseils de classe qu'en
plus Sacha il a tous les offres et tout
donc c'est normal
Daniel dans une autre vie j'aurais pu la
quête bon malheureusement je suis pas
Jean le poulain concentre-toi sur cette
vie là
je suis pas dans le poulain mais en vrai
Daniel je suis quasiment d'accord avec
tout ce que tu dis mamie et tout ce que
tu dis en off en plus tu es toujours
très sympathique donc alors il manque
deux points c'est pour tes outfit parce
que voilà c'est pas les chemisiers c'est
pas ouf mais je pense que tu peux faire
mieux la saison prochaine donc 1 8 parce
que tu es très sympa merci Sacha voilà
bien sûr je vais demander à Géraldine
maillet alors Daniel moi j'ai un peu les
chocottes
de noter la championne de Cyril parce
qu'en fait ça aurait été sa préférée
c'est un couple idéologiquement
totalement fusionnel tu es la femme du 8
mars et ça personne fait ça
exactement
je suis partagé c'est un conseil de
classe pour moi ce tension est très
risqué alors Daniel d'abord ton twerk 10
raconte à stablement ton autodérision 10
ton auto flagellation et ça c'est un
problème 10 et je voudrais que tu es
zéro je voudrais que ce soit un vrai
changement chez toi parfois j'ai
l'impression même que ton joue et ça ça
m'énerve un peu donc je veux que tu
arrêtes ça après c'est vrai que moi j'ai
du mal avec tes avis un peu tradirac
mais ça on l'a vu ici mais c'est ce qui
fait aussi le sel de l'émission parce
que si on était que de l'huile ce serait
pas une bonne sauce TPMP donc voilà en
gros voilà ça et parfois je trouvais que
sur tout ce qui est homophobie
transphobie tout ça il va falloir un peu
éclaircir tout ça parce que je trouve
que c'est un peu obscur mais sinon moi
je t'ai mis une très bonne note je t'ai
mis 6
ans
allez on va prendre
ce que j'adore
légère je crois sur ma note en fait
c'est l'histoire de ta vie
j'étais un peu dur non en fait j'étais
bien noté pour le côté chaudière parce
que je me retrouve beaucoup en toi
de très sympathique après je moi
j'aimerais te relooker vraiment si tu
accepté tu vois un petit relooking je
sais pas si tu as confiance en moi ou
pas
depuis qu'elle arrivait dans l'émission
on a fait 18 ans
des choses un peu comme ça tu me fais
confiance peut-être je peux augmenter ma
note après sur le bouton
nébuleux sur certains propos elle est
traditionnel elle vit avec son temps
90% de nos téléspects exactement
merci elle a raison tu sais quoi et même
là elle est plus âgée que la table
tu vois donc le plus puisses le pupitre
et les 30 ans avant
[Applaudissements]
tu lis les livres oui tu vois les films
et des invités tu travailles énormément
à autre chose à [__] non plus hein
et puis alors cette année grosse
révélation parce que effectivement tu es
devenu la chouchoute de Cyril et sa
championne
il y avait il y avait Pipo et Mario
maintenant il y a Cyril et Daniel c'est
vraiment
mais du coup alors c'est vrai que du
coup bah du coup
tu te cherches fais un petit peu
chaudière était un petit peu vieille
France et on sait quoi qui tu es elle
entre les deux c'est exactement
[Applaudissements]
tu veux qu'on fasse on va faire d'abord
Kelly ouais comme ça parce que Kelly
et après il y aura le
stagiaire
la danse le franc parler
la grande Barca le sourire le smile tu
es génial c'est bon tu as fini
la première c'est qu'on t'a présenté
maintes et maintes fois des mecs
le deuxième ça va t'enlever encore en
demi-point c'est le fait que je t'ai
envoyé plein de sites pour le plaisir
solitaire
[Applaudissements]
donc pour ça je te
mets un
bon ami
alors Daniel on l'a vu sur les images tu
as interpré incroyable vraiment pour moi
ce qu'on appelle un boule qui chamboule
néanmoins comme tu le sais le physique
ne suffit pas donc tu peux pas te
contenter de ton rôle de bimbo dans
l'émission j'ai trouvé que c'était
souvent en boucle sur les mêmes sujets
et de plus tu n'as pas souhaité
rencontrer mes chiens cette année ça m'a
fait beaucoup de peine sache-le donc
pour cette raison je te mets une note
encourageante un trois
c'est des vraies raisons
[Applaudissements]
dans la lignée de vos années
d'abstinence dans la vie vous nous avez
d'abord gratifié de très longs mois de
silence dans TPMP
le néant
et puis la carpe est devenue tigresse
oui la magie Cyril Hanouna a opéré il
vous a gratifié d'un compliment
merveilleux vous êtes devenu la star ça
championne et la galvaniser totalement
déchaîné vous avez pris deux fois la
parole en deux semaines
ce qui est beaucoup plus que certains
chroniqueurs n'est-ce pas Guillaume
absolue c'est deux prises de parole en
deux semaines je vous mets un très
prestigieux chers Daniel
Clément le stagiaire c'est-à-dire
quelque chose alors je dois dire pour
que tu penses ok alors en fait on parle
de chaudière mais je connais pas trop
ton niveau en plomberie mais je t'ai
quand même pour la porte
[Musique]
je vais dans donner mon avis sur toi ma
Daniel madame il m'a championne mon bébé
ce weekend
j'ai rencontré des gens et trois
personnes que j'ai rencontré m'ont dit
Cyril est-ce que Daniel sera là l'année
prochaine c'est ma préférée je vous jure
que c'est vrai je l'ai dit s'il n'y a
pas Daniel l'année prochaine
il n'y a pas de
donc forcément Daniel sera là je sais
pas si ce sera souvent
elle sera là
elle tournera comme elle a toujours rêvé
de faire
Dany
je suis un peu d'accord avec Gilles tu
as fait un début d'année poussif
été voilà on est à un moment il y avait
des jours où tu étais pas très présente
mais dès qu'on vient de chercher tu
donnes exactement ce que les
téléspectateurs ont envie d'avoir du
chaud du spectacle de la sincérité
de l'élégance
et puis Daniel
tu as décidé de participer au débat
et là Daniel tu t'es réveillé
et tu as été celle qui m'aime si j'ai pu
vérifier lui mars tu n'en as pas tu as
celle tu as celle qui avait le plus de
cours
Daniel tu as été formidable tu as été ce
que tout animateur rêve d'avoir comme
chroniqueuse
je fais le show tu donnes un avis
tranché
tu es toujours
contre tes petits camarades
un peu
voilà la manière de Gilles et dans un
autre sens
et Daniel c'est vrai que
tu ne recules jamais c'est à dire que
les gens peuvent te dire oui tu dis
n'importe quoi t'engueuler te bousculer
tu restes ce stand sur ta lignée la
seule chose que j'aurais à dire pour
l'année prochaine reste sur ta ligne ne
change rien affirme-t-on encore plus va
encore plus loin dans tes idées n'hésite
pas n'aie pas peur des autres et 80% du
temps à 80% du temps voire 90% du temps
le public est d'accord avec toi
donc Daniel tu as fait une année
exceptionnelle
c'est pour cette raison
pour la progression
pour le physique
pour
même si parfois je suis pas toujours
d'accord avec elle mais elle a des je
suis désolé pour le courage
Daniel Moreau qu'on soit d'accord avec
elle ou pas
en terme télévisuel
en terme
de bêtes télévisuelle
c'est une bête
elle est incroyable
c'est pour cette raison
je lui mets la note de 9 et demi
[Applaudissements]
c'est une erreur j'avais mis quatre et
demi
ma chérie
je ne brille que quand vous m'éclairez
[Applaudissements]
merci
on va voir ah bah tiens il y a la
moyenne des tutos c'est pas la même 4,2
et donc
tu es à 5,3 sur 10
ce qu'il aime forcément avec un Bebop
compliqué
merci à toi
[Applaudissements]